hello my name is Ted I am a former after
school teacher hi my name is Salani and
I'm a science teacher my name is Mandy
and I used to teach grades 6 through 12
hi my name is Stephanie and I am a
substitute teacher for high school
middle school and today we are going to
try school lunches I'm feeling a little
nervous I don't know a lie saying I'm
feeling like imma turn into a ninja
turtle after this so we're gonna eat 2
lunches today and this is gonna be the
first one hungry yes
well looking at it the safest thing
looks like the Tater Tot I was gonna say
the same thing I'm not - you know that
most tad dry presentation I give it a
well before judging it based on other
school lunches I guess it's about a 5
out of 5 I would actually be thrilled
that if any of my former students ate
this because I think for lunch they
mostly had energy drinks and things that
come in a bag like flamin hot business
and so I feel like there's actual maybe
nutrients and some of this that is ice
cold just the way I like - hey yeah you
want to I don't know if I could put one
of those in my mouth okay Cheers I'm so
terrible I put that in my mouth and
every drop of so I'll adjust and
instantly about the tater tots are
standard oh yeah
nice and chewy it seems like there's
some moisture and warmth on the bottom
of my burger so I'm a little excited for
that that might help but there are no
condiments that's fine burgers down but
listen and this is what we have to deal
with in schools with no lettuce tomato
no mustard or ketchup we have bigger
problems in this country okay I think
this takes me back to the worst
childhood memories I've ever had oh man
I wasn't ready
can I spit it out right here it is right
can we get some cash oh I don't know
what I can do after the tater tots cuz
it tasted like a kid still tastes like
the frozen I'm sorry okay nice a dirty
toughest hardest
don't tell me anything
oh my god I'm so full so all this is the
least scary thing I think I'm gonna get
rid into this Apple
great that sounds like a really good
Apple actually I'd start with the worst
part the worst part was the burger patty
was just drying not good well the Apple
is far and away the tastiest I would say
the burgers texture was really alarming
and the burger is definitely the worst
part like it was very hard and didn't
taste like real food my favorite part of
the entire meal probably we're
approaching it because it's almost over
am i excited to see what's next let's
see another plate of food to put to my
dome yeah you know what
let's do it well well well hmm this is
fancy a nice crisp Italian family
doesn't wasn't so bad but it'll little
cold this looks like some salad I've had
it my friend felt the smell of that
dressing that Italian dressing that's I
think 95% vinegar is just like really
it's screaming up my nostril we have a
salad great we got a little fruit cup
nice I got a piece of pizza uh-oh what's
this
Thomas piece of pepperoni pizzas not bad
it's your school for sure okay oh it
definitely has a sponge-like quality
yeah I'm conflicted it's all right it's
just a little you know I have a
different texture than normal pizza that
I would eat it's pizza so that part of
my brain is like this is good
I don't know it's strange we think about
it right like usually it you're excited
like pizzas always good news but I don't
know but because it's pizza I'm still
like should I have another buy like
what's about that pepperoni changes
things
exactly falen I'm cool with yeah
standard [ __ ] okay that is the exact
same Ataris dressing school cafeteria
and like a giant I think comes in like
five gallon drums am i liking this
better than the turkey burger on one
hand it's rude to come into BuzzFeed's
house and say this is bad food on the
other hand that food was bad I can't I
can't anymore that salad all right
fruit cup here we go all right let's see
about this from time that's good wow
that's really nice Kevin and put a lot
of sugar on stuff it tastes really good
weird right rooftop was good some
properties like a standard for the cup
from 19 1982
salad tastes like every salad from like
any buffet
this is actually better than the burger
though I must say I agree yeah I
definitely would eat this was happen in
the market in everything it was better
than that Turkey that's anything deeper
and I know I finished it leave that
whole burger out I always thought that
school lunches should be better but now
that I've actually had to eat them as an
adult I kind of feel a bit stronger
about that so the butter and the Apple
everything else
brave you mix up the pepperonis with the
whatever those hashbrowns tack tape oh
yeah I think a cheese that sounds really
good for me um the salad I would prefer
the dressing on the side maybe I need to
start an initiative at my school for
like better school lunches cuz if that's
what they're eating
no wonder they have attitudes in my
class
[Music]